[Music]
all right Samuel leaves here and today
we've got a very special guest we've got
a mortgage broker who specializes in
buying property and then recycling and
pulling your money out of the deals
which I know is a very exciting topic so
please welcome to the show mr. Kevin
Wright hello there great to have you on
the show thank you for coming down
preach it out the invites mmm tell us in
a nutshell what is it that you do what's
your background
well I'm a investor and a broker
mortgage broker is a probably
over-simplistic
I would say property finance brokers I
think is more accurate because my cell
from a business partner Tony we do a lot
more than mortgages but also on the on
the back of that I have a training
business where are trained people to
intelligently and creatively finance
their property deals that's fantastic so
what are we talking putting your money
in doing up and then pulling out your
money those types of deals like people
are probably very familiar with I know
back when I started in 2008 you'd buy a
property below market value here and
they need to refinance it back to its
true value we're not talking about that
but we are talking about with we're
talking a variation of it okay you know
I mean now I was actively brokering for
investors at that time you know with the
old mortgage Express and the other thing
you know I mean I guys that I was
brokering them and they were buying five
a week yeah because they could at that
time yeah and you know and getting all
their money out on the day they complete
in late yeah I did one deal like that
and then the change but yeah it's kind
of like there it's not as maybe seamless
as that was but it's the nearest legal
equivalent to that and that's the stuff
that I devised probably about 2011 2012
because oh I'd seen that what investors
wanted I've seen it didn't work anymore
so I devised some creative ways to buy
property to the mirrored it as closely
as as we could do legally that's great
do you think that that strutted
is risky in today's market with when
you're relying on builders sticking to
budget and time scale you were relying
on value as being in a good mood yeah is
the strategy does it come with risk it
does and the the better your due
diligence is the more you're able to
mitigate that risk but you know I mean
anything in life is risky yeah so you
know you can't eliminate risk but
certainly with some intelligence you can
mitigate it yeah you know and so you
know builders and and tradesmen can can
let you down but you should factor in
some contingency that that you allow
them and go missing for a few days or a
few weeks so it's all it's all about
it's all about risk management I think
so and and understanding what's a good
deal yeah absolutely I mean the strategy
of buying and pulling your money out is
one way of buying property we've no
money or little money it's it's a
strategy that I don't sort of talk about
in my book because it is difficult it
does take unit you need to know people
in them to like yourself that can find
the lending because I'm sure a lot of a
lot of brokers if you ask them to do
this to fit your us to do would say
absolutely not so what why don't you why
don't we start just buy for anyone that
doesn't know anything about this
strategy for anyone that's for anyone
that doesn't even know what bridging yes
why don't you just define what what is a
bridging loan and how does it work
bridging loans a short term finance
mortgage ism by contrast and medium to
long term finance so bridging loans
some of you take it for typically a few
months to allow you to get into a
property that would be difficult to buy
with a mortgage either the speed at
which it needs to be bought let's say
you've got a distressed seller and I
don't listen mean financially distressed
but they've got they've got a reason to
need to be out of that property and they
can't sit around waiting for six nine
twelve months to get to get the asking
price or somewhere close to it so
there's summat going on in their life
that that means that they need need
to get rid of it so it's finding it's
finding that the you know the it's not
it's not an uncommon term to those in
property motivated sellers yeah so it's
about finding motivated sellers and it's
also about finder so and they if they
need to quit complete quickly you know
in a matter of weeks rather than months
like a mortgage then a bridging loan
acts quickly you know you can often
complete in 28 days you know in fact
more auction purchases which mostly have
to complete within 28 days almost all
auction purchases are bought either with
cash or bridging fine don't talk to me
about auction and you've been there
racing yeah yeah and I appreciate your
support helping out with that you know
some sort of stepping in and also moral
support as well yeah attic yeah why
don't you give us a case today of a good
typical example of a property whereby
you would buy it and then pull your
money out give me give me the figures
and run through a case study with my
it's a couple we now Joe and Jane now
you know I'd do some stuff like that and
you know they do some bigger conversion
stuff but now and again they'll do a
little flip deal if they can make some
money now I'm gonna tell you about the
flip deal I did for them but also bear
in mind that if you want to buy and hold
it rent it and pull your money out it
would work for that as well sure so they
he'd found just a normal terraced
property down in the West Country and
but it was in a bit of a state and you
know the sort of ones where they haven't
been touched for 20-25 years and you
know some people refer to him as little
time capsules yeah so everything's dated
swirly carpets avocado bathroom sweet
you know all of that sort of stuff so he
needed he needed garden and refurb in so
[Music]
it was probably in to poorer condition
to get a mortgage so therefore the only
real option was to buy it with cash
or use bridging finance now the thing
about PE I think we all know cash buyers
not necessary in property
but this is a universal experience we
all know what cash buyers do when they
want to buy something they hammer you
down on the price
yeah yes buyers don't pay top dollar so
bridging allows you to adopt the
behaviors of a cash buyer so you can
think like they think you can act like
they act you can negotiate like they
negotiate you can buy the properties
that they buy and you can make the
profits that they make yeah so bridging
allows you to complete fast so you can
get into that into that market so Joe
and Jane we've done quite a few bridging
deals for them so they're familiar with
it now
so they made a what you can call it you
know an adventuress offer if you like on
the basis that they could help these
people help them move on with their with
their life and and buy the property
quickly and they did so they made an
offer of 50,000 km but if it was if it
was the first offer anyway
the offer their offer was accepted at
50,000 yeah yep okay so we did a
bridging loan based on that now then
they then spent fifteen thousand on the
refurb yep and using some of the
techniques that are you I teach people
to get the best value refinance that you
can and there's there's a process that
you need to go through and most people
don't do it and that's why they they get
down valuations they got it revalued at
95,000 that's incredible
Wow so bought 450 spent 15 got it
revalued at 95 so then they pulled out
presumably all of their money well they
but though they sold they sold it they
could of yeah but they could have then
got a let's say a 75% mortgage based on
ninety five thousand and pulled out most
of their money yeah yeah and then rigid
out covered them all games maybe there
no money down deal yeah well no I'd say
no money left in they did put some money
down they did put some money down yeah
but they got it back at I think they got
out all but
yeah put it about 5,000 pounds yeah they
left they left incredible incredible so
what are some of the I know that this is
something that you go more in detail
with with your clients but give us just
a few pearls of wisdom about what are
some of the golden nugget pieces of
advice in order to raise the value
because if you've bought something for
say 50 grand and spent fifteen thousand
pounds on it
how on earth for anyone listening can
that be considered by a valuer worth to
be ninety five thousand pounds surely
wouldn't they just look at it and say
you bought if in 15 15 it's where 65 how
do you do that they do really but so
where a lot of investors go wrong is
they is an over-reliance on comparable
values so running around finding
properties that have sold in the same or
Jason streets for you know between
ninety and a hundred thousand and then
making their their main reason why it
should be valued
you know 95 yeah but that doesn't really
cut it with valuers what they want to
see is show us what you've done to make
the difference so it's about creating a
robust case for disparity yes we bought
it at 50 but we've done a full refurb
and and here's pictures here's his work
schedule is a valuation report that
we've done ourselves that confirms that
it's worth ninety five thousand so you
know it's all those sort of things so
it's a bet put in a robust case for what
I call disparity yeah sure yes it was in
a certain condition when you bought it
but it's not now we've we've we've added
that sort of value so that valuation
then you said when you put together a
valuation
what what is that valuation is that
Ric's valuation so you get you get a
Ric's valuer so the first person to have
to convince them is the Rick's value are
pretty rapid failure your own Rick's
value is that easy to do it's easy that
sometimes in others nothing's guaranteed
yeah yeah okay so you know nothing is
foolproof yeah yeah but it's it's by
understanding what you're doing
you're shifting the odds II further in
your favor yeah exactly yeah so you're
mitigating the risk again of a refinance
day on valuation sometimes it works
better than others
yeah so you're gonna you're gonna find a
property what would you say would how
would you dispose really good
opportunity like that
what kind of key things would you be
looking for it doesn't have to be but it
helps if it's vacant yeah because if no
one's living there something's happened
okay maybe they've moved out for another
job maybe they moved out to be near
family
maybe they'd emigrate so that's on the
terms of getting a good deal because
it's empty
and then what about is there anything
that you look for in regards to how to
really uplift the value if there's a
specific problem with it so for me the
but the best dealers are the ones you
actually can't get mortgages Iran right
now yeah because you know linearity
question how many mortgage dependent
buyers are interested in buying are
mortgageable properties no none exactly
yeah yeah so when you look for a
moldable property your competitors
largely fall by the wayside yeah so
there's much less competition so cash
offers only on the description yep it's
a good thing to look for of course it
could be because it's got a mine under
it or something but that's a good thing
it you need to do diligence now look at
the other side of the fence because if
you own an immortal property if you're
the owner yeah you'd have worked out who
your target market is who's going to buy
my property the cash buyer and that man
oh that's right but there's there's also
a further bit of thinking that goes on
there the owner of an unmolded property
says gonna be a cash buyer but they know
what cash buyers do the same as same as
your media yeah so they're already
primed to be hit on the price to be
hammered down on the price so they've
got it up for an asking price but don't
really expect to sell it yeah for that
yeah so so there's two key things so
that is the main is the main trick
buying a property
at a very very bargain price that means
a lot of work yeah is that the crooks oh
yeah the more work you needs the TV you
can buy it yeah if you can buy an
absolute bargain property there's a lot
of work brilliant because then chances
are spend some money on it get it up to
scratch convince a Rick's value your
Vic's value that actually it's worth a
lot more now and then you can then
recycle you my yeah fantastic
one of the things that a lot of people
have been going crazy about recently is
the new Kent reliance changes because
can't rely on so now saying that they
will let you refinance the next day or
as soon as the works are done we know
that that's not a massive deal because
there's already lenders that do that and
have been doing that for years
but but but people didn't know that it
seems not but can't realize were a very
big famous well-known I do residential
property yeah I mean camping are a
decent lender and you know it's great to
have fantastic yeah you know it's great
to have them switch sides if you like
from day one lender or from six-month
lenders yeah today one lenders yeah so
it's good for them to hop over to the
other side but even if there was already
lenders doing that but people didn't
know the fact that that's working people
up and now they do know that you can
refine us next day what do you think
that that means to to investors the fact
that they've realized they can do this
now and how will that change people I
think you know if people are going to do
a buy refurb and and refinance deal you
know to use my brain Bruce Harkey okay
yeah it gives them another angle to do
it and so I think you know the the
publicity that Kent reliance have got
because they are good lender you know I
mean they do things that normal by to
let didn't lenders won't do you know
they'll they'll lend on HMOs they'll
lend to limited companies so you know
most of my clients use Kent reliance so
when they change the rules I think
that's why all my device work wherever
the nerve could be yeah and any in you
know any extra lenders is in a given
space it you know is to be welcomed yeah
how many other lenders on the market
either that will let you refinance the
next day if you sort of bringing
commercial lenders as well probably
about a dozen about a dozen
yeah so what does the process look like
we've can't really
you bought it cause really it's not
quite as simple as just refinancing the
next day potentially because you're
gonna have to tell us what the process
model I mean I mean next is a is a bit
of an over exaggerating unless you've
got very fast biodiversity air I guess
what it means is that you know as soon
as you've done the refurb you're
eligible to apply for it for a refund
there's no limit yeah it could be you
know I mean it could be just a quick you
know like cosmetic refurb for a couple
of weeks it could be something a bit
heavier take your ten weeks yeah
but whenever you're finished then you
can make your application and they would
look at it now they would need to check
that you actually you actually own it
and when you bought it
and they would either do that on the
Land Registry or ask for your solicitors
completion statement but then they'll
they'll just under ideas normal so their
underwriting process is no real
different I mean they won't go above
seventy five percent in that so that you
know the ID and 85 percent deals they
you know you can't get them within six
months it's kept at 75 percent yeah but
it'll just be they're all real
underwriting process you know you'll put
the application in there lasts for
certain documentation they'll send a
value or a out and the value will want
to see the work that you've done of
course to uplift the veg so would you
always recommend keeping receipts I'd
always recommend keeping them but not
necessarily showing them if they're too
cheap let them think that you've spent
more than you have I just let them make
their own come to their own conclusion
yeah and if you do a comprehensive work
schedule yeah they should be at a
workout what what you most likely would
spend if you've got a build around to do
yeah and you're gonna show them before
and after pictures yeah you're gonna
leave them before actually after but
just with them to take home yeah
brilliant brilliant so what would you
say to someone who had a lot of cash say
someone it's someone who's maybe got a
few hundred thousand pounds would they
be better off still going down the
bridging route or they'd be better off
to just put all their money in do the
deal haul all their money out and then
just rinse and repeat I would say if
you've got cash you should use it you
because you got no boring costs yeah
and I think you think also it depends at
what stage you're at because what I see
a lot of people come in coming into
property you know if you see them in
three or four times three years time
they've progressed yeah they're not
still doing if they started off doing
little too out too damn refurbs they're
not still doing that yeah so they're
progressing you know that you know
they've they've earned their Spurs if
you like they get boring on that yeah
and and so they want to challenge
themselves and is year by year they do
bigger and bigger deals you know and you
know I've seen you know people come
through and within five years they're
doing new build stuff bill to rent you
know building you know eight ten units
on a side a lot of profit in those yeah
so you know I think if you if for the
scale of deal you want to do if you've
got cash you should you should use it
now principally because you've got zero
borrowing costs yeah now where you
should use bridging is if it is if your
cash is tied up in a deal let's say
you're waiting to refinance or you're
waiting to sell it and another quarter
of a deal comes along yeah that you
think damn I really wish I had my cash
yeah because I don't want to let that
deal go that's the time to use bridging
because it gets you into the next deal
that if you just used your cash you you
would have missed yeah absolutely yeah
and then you're only paying the bridging
costs when there's a real need to do so
yeah yeah and as you progress probably
the size of deal that you take on will
outstrip the cash that you've got so
then as you progress and do bigger and
bigger deals so you might buy you know a
block of small offices and you want to
convert them to maybe I don't know
fifteen apartments well you may your
cash might not stretch that far so going
you put your cash in at the front end
and then borrow the rest to either
complete the purchase or and and or
building
yeah someone that say just got 10 20
thousand pounds in the bank is there
anything they can do yeah I think so
they're going to be limited
geographically on where they can buy
property maybe not London maybe not
London yeah yeah but this you know
certain areas of the country you know in
the north you know in Wales you know and
those sort of areas you know Midlands to
in certain areas you know you pick and
pick up a property with that sort of
cash you know I mean there's a there's a
there's a bridging deal now that works
it's called a refurbishment bridge so
they will lend you 70 percent of the
purchase price 100% of the refurb cost
yeah it's great yeah
so you know you know if you're buying
property for for say 50 grand and you've
got 20 grand well okay so you'd need 15
grand as you deposit then you've got a
bit more to cover your legals and stamp
duty you don't need to worry about the
refurb cost because they're lending you
know yeah so yeah you can do those sort
of deals yeah fantastic yeah what the
kind of properties are you investing at
the moment there I mean I started
investing in 1983 when I first did my
refurb so I've done by like the cells
I've done by the holes I've been single
lates
I've got multi let's didn't call her my
HMOs when I was doing them but they were
HMOs and modern parlance I've done new
build so at the moment I'm taking a
break from actively investing because
I'm building two businesses I've now got
the business partner Tony brought in
about four years ago on the brokerage so
we could you know have greater capacity
yeah and you know we've now got staff
working with us and there so we're
building the brokerage and I'm also
building my education business as well
yeah now lesson I've learned in in my
earlier years is spread yourself too
thin Lee and you just do a bad job of
everything correct so I've got I've got
two businesses I'm focus on now so I've
shelved the property business I'm still
a knurled
but I shoved the property business you
know actively pursuing another moment
yeah but I would oh I'll go back to it
yeah because you know I mean it's bit
you know anyone that seem proper now
it's a bit like a drug in it you know
yeah it's addictive it is it pulls you
back in yeah and it's been doing that on
and off you know for the fact that
you're financing deals for people on a
day-in day-out basis means that you're
very up-to-date you know what's going on
it's not like you're you're behind the
times that's all in fact you're one of
the most ahead of the times people
probably around that's fantastic so what
are you visions then for the future what
are your plans over the next 12 months
on the brokerage side we're just we're
just pushing that forward yeah and you
know Tony's based in the office all week
so it's it's prudent for him to do the
processing and with the staff that we
have working for us person I tend to be
out and about more speaking at events
running running training the events and
mentoring people so I'll often set up a
DL if you like in terms of how to
structure and once we come clear with
our client what's the most the proven
way to structure the deal hand it over
to Tony and then Tony does it from there
that's right yeah so it's a good
division of labour so what is it that
really gets you up in the morning then
what is it that really makes you tick
what would you say your your purpose is
your mission I've I feel incredibly
fortunate because in a business context
I only ever talk to someone that's
investing in priority so you know those
are my conversations every day whether
it's someone that's asking a bit of
advice someone that that you know how to
structure a deal someone that wants
particular finance for a property they
they bought or wanna buy or talking
about people about you know my different
training events that's my conversation
and you know they're the most
enlightening and invigorating
conversations I can imagine so yeah you
know I mean it's a bit of a cliche but
you know there's that sign that you know
if you love what you do you never work
in your life true and we've got a sour
feel pretty much like that
that's brilliant brilliant and when you
can help people at the same time and
lived in what you're doing that's
fantastic yeah so what would be the best
way if people wanted to reach out to you
in regards to the broker yet things
what's your website its puzzle positive
property finance co uk fantastic
positive property finance code at UK and
as you and also Tony yeah and we're what
I'm tonight we're off to the property
investors circle yeah and you're gonna
be speaking during a Q&A yeah and
basically everybody you any financial
questions yeah they're like so that's
gonna be really excited to shoot from
the here thank you so much for coming
down it's nice to have you in my home I
look forward to spending evening with
you as well I'm looking forward to it
yes thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time